knowing these methods when you talk to
people especially in civilian life how
do you know
who's lying to you and not
that gets to be
more into the trained skill side of
things there's body cues there's micro
expressions i'm not a big fan of
i don't believe that micro expressions
alone do anything i also don't believe
that micro expressions without without
an effective bass line do anything so
don't for a second think that i'm
all the people out there pitching that
you can tell if someone's lying to you
just by looking at their face it's all
it's all baloney in my world that's
baloney like the way you move your eyes
is something like that without knowing a
baseline without knowing that individual
for that individual then you actually
don't know and an individual's baseline
is based on education culture life
experience you name it right so this is
huge
but when you combine
facial expressions with body movements
body language nonverbal cues and you add
on top of that effective elicitation
techniques that you are in control of
now you have a more robust
platform to tell if someone's lying to
you so there there's like a
set of like interrogation
trajectories you can go down they can
help you
figure out a person technically their
interview interview
like this concepts correct because in
interrogation an interrogation is
something very different than an
interview and in the world of
professionals and interrogation is very
different what's the difference the the
nature of how relaxed the thing is or
what so in an interrogation there's a
clear pattern of dominance there's no
equality got it also there's no escape
you are there until the interrogator is
done with you right anybody who's ever
been reprimanded by mom and dad knows
what an interrogation feels like
anybody's ever been called into the
principal's office or the boss's office
that's what interrogation feels like you
don't leave until the boss says you can
leave and you're there to say to answer
questions the boss asks questions an
interview is an equal exchange of ideas
you are in control of this interview
for sure but if we were having coffee i
could take control if i wanted to take
control if i wanted to ask you personal
questions i would if i wanted to talk to
you about your background i could
why am i in control of this interview
exactly because the person in control is
the person asking questions
yeah
i'm sitting here as you've spoken about
uh my power here is i'm the quiet one
listening
you're exactly right guess where this
conversation goes yeah anywhere you
choose to take it because you're the one
asking questions every time i answer a
question i am creating a pattern of
obedience to you
which subliminally subconsciously makes
me that much more apt to answer your
questions of course you can always turn
and ask start asking me questions it
should you know uh so but you're saying
that there's through this
through conversation you can call it
interviewing you can start to
you can start to see
um
see cracks in the story of the person
and the degree to which they exaggerate
or lie or
uh to see how much they could be trusted
that kind of stuff what i'm saying is
that through a conversation you develop
a baseline right like even just in the
last the last the first part of our
conversation we've i've been able to
create some baseline elements about you
you've been able to create baseline
elements about me maybe they're just not
friend of mine
from those baselines now we can push
through more intentional questions
to test
got it to test whether or not the person
is being truthful because they're
operating within their baseline or if
you are triggering
sensitivities outside of their baseline
and then you can start to see their
tails
that's fascinating yeah baseline like uh
even even like yeah the tells right the
the eye contact like you you've probably
already formed a bass line that i i have
trouble making eye contact and so like
so if you ask me difficult questions and
i'm not making eye contact maybe that's
not a good signal of me lying or
whatever correct because i always have
trouble making eye contact stuff like
that that's really fascinating the
majority of your eye movement is to the
right yeah my your right my left yes
right which is usually someone who's if
you ask micro expressionists that's
someone who's referencing fact yeah
that's not necessarily what's happening
for you because you're pulling concepts
out of the air so it's also a place
where you reference something other than
fact it's a place for you to find
creativity yeah so if i just thought
that you were lying because you look up
into the right
i would be wrong that's so fascinating
and a lot of that has to do with like
habits that are formed and all those
kinds of things or maybe some right hand
left hand type of situation right eye
dominance yeah right that's going to
make you look to the right
is this a science or an art it's a bit
of both i would say that like all good
art
art is taught from a foundation of
skills
and those skills are
are
plated are taught in a very structured
manner and then the way that you
use the skills after that that's more of
the artistic grace
so i've always called espionage an art
spying is an art
being able to hack human beings is an
art but it's all based in a foundation
of science you still have to learn how
to mix the color palette and use certain
brushes
you